Speaker 1: All right. Listen. I have absolutely
no problem criticizing someone I normally praise
or praising someone I normally criticize. Broken
clocks can sometimes be right. Functioning clocks
sometimes run out of battery and give you
the wrong time of day. So the point is we
evaluate each thing individually. And last night.
Tulsi Gabbard, former Democrat Tulsi Gabbard,
no longer a Democrat who now supported like
Herschel Walker and look, the worst of the worst,
Kerry Laich, etc. In 2022, she filled in for
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson last night,
and she interviewed habitual liar Republican
elect George Santos. And I have to tell you,
she really did a pretty damn good job. And my
earpiece is flying out and I want to be able to
hear this. So let me tuck it back in neatly there.
She actually does a good job of calling it what it
is. Take a listen to Tulsi and Jorge Santos.
Speaker 4: The results that people are.
Speaker 3: Looking.
Speaker 4: For are
called into question when you tell BLITZER.
Speaker 1: And he increasingly gets flustered,
which is great embellishment.
Speaker 4: And this is this is,
I think one of the biggest concerns,
Congressman elect, is that you don't really
seem to be taking this seriously. You've
apologized. You said you've made mistakes,
but you've outright lie. A lie is not an
embellishment on a resume. You said you
worked at Goldman Sachs and Citigroup, but they've
said we've got no record of this guy working for
us. You've said you've gone to and graduated
from these universities, but they've said,
well, we've got no record of that. These are
blatant lies. And it calls into question how your
constituents and the American people can believe
anything that you may say when you are standing on
the floor of the House of Representatives.
Speaker 1: Now, this is a question.
Speaker 4: Supposedly fighting for
them. That's the real issue here.
Speaker 3: But look, I and I agree with what
you're saying. And as I stated and I continue,
we can debate my my resumé and how I work.
Speaker 1: You realize it's not really for debate.
Speaker 3: Though, with firms such as gold.
Speaker 4: Is it debatable or is it just.
Speaker 3: Far less debatable or is that
debatable? No, no, it's not false at all. It's
debatable. It's totally false. Explain to you what
you can do in private equity in capital intro via
servicing limited partners and general partners.
And we can have this discussion that's going to
go way above the American people's head. Yes.
Speaker 1: It would be too complicated for the
American people for me to explain why
it's not really a lie for me to say I
worked for Goldman when I did, and because
I worked for a company that had Goldman as
a client and blah, blah, blah. Well, why
did you put Goldman on your resume then?
Speaker 3: It's not what I campaigned on.
I campaigned on delivering results for the
American people by lowering inflation. I can
sit down if you want to have that discussion.
I'd be glad to, Tulsi, to explain that to you
and make sure that we we settle the score.
Speaker 4: This is not about settling scores. And
I think you just you just kind of highlighted,
I think my concern, the concern that
people at home have. You're saying that
this discussion will go way above the heads
of the American people, basically insulting
their intelligence. So not only are you.
Speaker 3: Now that that's not what I'm.
Speaker 4: Saying, that you told.
Speaker 1: It's exactly what he's saying.
Speaker 4: But you're saying that you.
Speaker 3: Can't not when.
Speaker 4: You say that your
constituents would actually be able to.
Speaker 3: I cannot explain it in a way.
Speaker 4: That you guys.
Speaker 3: Give me the time I
can easily give. If you give me the time, I
can easily explain it for you as as in when
investors are looking for capital and I'm sitting
there doing due diligence on the decision, on the
appetite and what they're looking at.
Speaker 1: This is all to explain why
he claimed to work at Goldman Sachs when he
did not. When Tulsi is not buying your lies,
you know you're digging pretty deep here. Here's
another clip from this interview. And again,
to tell us his credit, she confronted
him and he got increasingly flustered
because he should, because he's lying to them.
Speaker 3: And now I want to put this behind me so
I can deliver for the American people.
Speaker 4: The thing is, Congressman elect.
Integrity means, yes, carrying yourself with
honor. But it means it means telling the truth,
being a person of integrity. And if I were one
of those in New York's third district right now,
now that the election is over and I'm finding out
all of these lies that you've told, not just one
little lie or one little embellishment,
these are blatant lies. My question is,
do you have no shame? You have no shame.
And the people are now you're asking to
trust you to go and be their voice for them,
their families and their kids in Washington.
Speaker 3: Tulsi I can say the same
thing about the Democrats and the
party. Look at Joe Biden. Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: But don't the Democrats
have shame? But we're not talking about
them. We're talking about you claiming
that you were Jewish when you weren't.
Speaker 3: Lying to the American people
for 40 years. He's the president
of the United States Democrats.
Speaker 1: But Biden once lied resoundingly.
Speaker 3: Support him today. Have no shame,
because, look, this has made this very clear.
Speaker 4: Not this is not about Democratic Party,
though. This is about your relationship,
frankly, with the people who've entrusted
you to go and and fight for them. And I
think one of the questions that that really.
Speaker 1: By the way, asking whether he has
shame as she sits in Tucker Carlson's chair
is pretty rich, but this is not about Tulsi.
Speaker 4: It's home to a lot of people. Is
is are you Jewish? We've got a letter that
your campaign sent out earlier this year
which reads as follows As a proud American
Jew, I've been to Israel numerous times for
educational business and leisurely trips. You
said there in that letter that you are, quote,
a proud American Jew. How do you.
Speaker 3: How do.
Speaker 4: You explain that?
Speaker 3: My heritage is Jewish. I've always
identified as Jewish. I was raised of practice.
Speaker 1: He just said in the other interview
I played for you that he has always
identified as Catholic. But here he says,
I've always identified as Jewish and Catholic.
Speaker 3: I think I've gone through this even
I've not not been raised a practicing Jew.
I've always joked with friends and circles,
even with in the campaign. I say, Guys,
I'm Jewish. Remember, I was raised
Catholic. So look, I understand everybody man.
Speaker 1: To see is just not buying it. So good
job by Tulsi. I have no problem praising her,
even though I think most of her contributions to
American politics are quite negative and Santos
is just so dishonest. In the earlier interview,
he says, No, no, no, no, listen, I've always
said I'm Catholic here. He says, No, no,
no, no, no. I've always identified as Jewish,
but I'm also kind of Catholic and this and that,
and I'm Jewish. And there's a
hyphen, guys. There's a hyphen.
The hyphen makes all the difference in the world.
This guy should resign. I hope that Republicans
say you can't stay, dude, you got to go. We will
follow it and let you know, make sure you were
subscribed to the YouTube channel. Over 3 million
different people watched clips in November and
didn't subscribe. If we can just get a fraction
of those folks to hit the subscribe button on
YouTube will be at 2 million subscribers before
you know it. Quick break and we'll be right back.
The David Pakman Show is an audience
supported podcast, YouTube channel,
radio show and television program. I encourage
you to sign up at join Packman dot com. It's
a very, very small and inexpensive way to
get some great perks and support the work
that we do every day. We do an extra show
for our members called The Bonus Show. We
also offer commercial free audio and video streams
of the show. And membership includes invitations
to the members only town halls, the next of
which will be scheduled very, very soon. Sign
up at join Packman dot com. You can
use the coupon code 24 starts now
that's two four starts now. For a sizable
discount off of the cost of a membership,